good day everyone
a very warm welcome to this online
webinar titled
participatory design and its emotional
impact on singapore and southeast asian
communities
this event is presented by the design
singapore council
in partnership with participate in
design as well as
we create studio and supported by the
national design center
today's webinar consists of mainly three
portions
we will be starting off with a short
sharing by participate in design
as well as a hands-on activity please
make sure that you have a pen and paper
close by
following that we have a sharing by we
create studio
before we end off with a q a session
where you would be able to ask us peter
some questions
in the spotlight today we have larry
young
executive director participate in design
architect trisha lim founder and
principal architect
we create studio i will now hand over
the time to our speakers for today
to tell you more about themselves and
the work that they do
larry over to you all right you know as
we all know i mean today we're here to
learn more about participation design
and its emotional impact on communities
right so my name is larry i'm from
participating in design a non-profit
design organization
that really focuses on participation
design in singapore
now but before i begin um i would just
like to share a very um small little
exercise with all of you
all right now just get ready a paper and
a pen
and just switch on your camera all right
now what i'm going to do in the next few
slides
in a very very short activity is that
i'm going to ask you a
question okay and i want you guys to
actually sketch out
your answer on the paper and show it
onto the camera
all right a very simple activity right
and i think hopefully you can on your
cancer everybody can see you
right so i can't really tell whether you
guys are ready but i will come to a
count of three
i'm gonna ask my question and i'm gonna
give you five seconds
all right so the first question is this
now design the bus all right i'll give
you guys five seconds
okay five four
three two one
all right just stop whatever you're
sketching yeah i'm just thinking
anybody actually would like to share and
we didn't reflect what you guys have
drawn onto the screen so that everybody
can see you guys
yeah what have you drawn
wow okay i saw a lot of bars
a lot of us now this is not new okay i
mean
a lot of you actually are sharing this
right when i asked you guys to draw a
bus
correct now i'm gonna give you another
five seconds
okay think of this question all right
design a better way for people to enjoy
flowers in their homes alright again
five seconds
five four three
two one all right let's just stop
sketching and again i would like you
guys to show on the camera what you guys
have drawn now look around you uh what
you guys have drawn
all right i can't really see okay i see
some wow very cool
i saw this as some like um a shoe rack
kind of thing
and a lot of very creative things yeah i
saw grace as well with very beautiful
sketch over there and danny too
i can't really tell what is that but
that looks really interesting danny
all right so um you know i'm gonna ask
one more question
all right one last question for this
activity
and i want you guys to think about it
again five seconds very quickly
now design a playground okay five
seconds for you guys
five four three
two one look around your screen and see
what your neighbors have been drawing
all right i thought there's a seesaw
danny have drawn a seesaw david has
drawn a slide
all right the kill have drawn and you
sent it i think yeah very interesting
but a lot of you drawn swings and slides
all right now i'm going to ask you guys
one last question for this exercise
design a better way for children to play
enjoy
play okay five seconds five
four three two
one all right very quickly i just want
you guys to stop drawing and just share
whatever you have
just now you guys draw swings and slides
now let's see what you guys have
i saw there's some computer games
there's some vlogs there's some people
holding hands while kristen is a very
nice drawing holding hands
all right i think you guys did a great
job around applause for all of you
great artists out there now i think you
guys are
thinking right why do i even actually
ask these questions
now if you think about it for the two
questions i've asked they're basically
asking very similar things
right but sometimes by just tweaking my
question a little bit
and not focusing on the what but also
the
why and the how and just rephrasing the
way we ask certain questions
you know we can actually get a design
something that's more emotional right
for example if we just design a bus
there's really nothing emotional to talk
about but by just tweaking the question
to
us to express a little bit more interest
in caring for the users
how can i have a better way to enjoy
flowers recreate the emotional space and
the emotional design
that amplifies feelings and emotions
and that is what participatory design is
all about right
we want to allow people to build an
emotion to a space or product
through the process of asking the right
questions
and that is exactly the role we do in
participating in design to create a very
safe space the very inclusive space
to let everybody talk about design in a
very inclusive manner
now when people are exposed to an
emotive design
they actually see design they see colors
and they feel something special they
feel something unique and
they feel something that is meaningful
to them right and they can feel the
emotional space and design can amplify
that feeling
so how does participatory design
facilities creation or such
emotional space or space that people
will feel connected to
i think that is for today i will be
sharing three very simple examples
of how we use the participatory design
process
to create such spaces all right
so the first one i think is a very cool
example in singapore now in singapore we
have a lot of places called
the void deck space which is on the
first floor you see over there
this is actually where a senior activity
center is
and when we got this project we were
actually tasked to design a community
kitchen within this space
now if you think about it as a designer
or as an artist
right it's a very simple job right i go
in i design the space i plug some
concepts in there i get my money and i
get off
but i think in the participation design
process we want to be a little bit more
inclusive because
we want to make sure when we design the
space senior will actually use it
we want to design a space whereby you
know when we design it seriously if
you're proud of it
so how can we then design this
experience so we actually went into the
space and started talking to seniors
you know hey uncle would you like to see
a community teaching here
and i must say the response was not very
positive
when we first entered the space seniors
told us
i do not want the community kitchen and
i hated it if you build it here i would
never come to the center again
we got this kind of very hostile kind of
feedback
so for this if you were to just build a
kitchen without consulting the seniors
likelihood is you will build a space
that no one will use
so how did we overcome that
so as a collective and as a as a design
studio
we actually work with our volunteers to
just talk to the seniors we want to
understand
is there a reason why you don't like a
community kitchen
like why is that so right and we started
observing the seniors talking to them
and we found out the magic spark is that
the center space is not very huge
and seniors love to play bingo they are
very afraid by having a community
kitchen
you know they will have no more bingo
space they will have no more space to
play bingo
so that was when we decided if we want
to get the seniors to talk about the
community kitchen
we need to tweak our question right
instead of asking them what kind of
kitchen would you like to see
we asked them this how can we co-create
a kitchen such that we can cook and at
the same time play
bingo and then go the seniors very
excited because
bingo is something they really enjoy and
with that
you know we started to have um you know
different kind of we started going down
more often
observing how they play bingo and we
started talking to the center staff
and we even do a design workshop and a
design workshop that is very inclusive
such that you know we conducted in
different language and dialects
so that seniors will feel comfortable
enough to be part of the discussion
to be part of the whole um you know
co-creation process
and this is the end outcome you know
seniors were consulted in every detail
of the kitchen design and they say yeah
why not we create
you know cabinets that are movable so
that we have space for bingo and yet
there's space for cooking
right and this is the end product that
they've created and initially i told you
right seniors say they will not go to
the kitchen
if even if you build a kitchen for me i
would never attend the courses because i
hate cooking
and this is the end result look at it
you know seniors actually came forward
uh in fact seniors who hardly come up
their home started coming down to the
center
and they love the center so much you
know and and they are so bonded to it
and this whole process you know really
allowed something
to happen something that the seniors
initially do not enjoy
but in the end built a lot of emotions
and a lot of
good feelings about it and it became a
space where seniors can co-create and a
space where seniors can you know make
friends with one another
and that is how participating design can
create a kind of emotional attachment
now in the second example i'm going to
share with you is about a creation of a
public space
now for this one we were actually
commissioned um to design a public
to design a public space a public art
installation
and um you know in a traditional
approach right
what we do is that we just get a
designer or artist to come in with a
design
and yeah maybe maybe the residents just
kind of paint a little bit of things
there and that's about it to free up the
colors right
but in this case want to go beyond that
because we feel that the creation of the
public art installation
could actually allow residents to feel
more emotionally attached to it and
there are a lot of opportunities
to celebrate you know this community
that reside
in the neighborhood so what we did was
we decided to work with
a senior activity center that is just
situated next to the artwork
and we say hey you know what you guys
are just next to the artwork would you
guys be keen
to co-create the artwork together with
us so that you can showcase your work
to the neighborhood right and for this
group of seniors um they are mostly
you know seniors who do not have a home
to turn to
and during that period whereby we are
co-creating artwork it kind of aligns
with the luna
with the lunar new year right and as you
all know
for lunar new year we have this thing
called the reunion dinner
and for this group of seniors a reunion
dinner is always not a happy thing for
them because
they have no family to turn to and every
year they will just have to spend the
reunion dinner eating
just with the center stuff you know and
and to them it can be quite depressing
um
period so the artists um actually took
point of it
and they were saying you know what why
not let's design something together
let's design
a an art installation where we can
create our own reunion dinner
and this seniors got really excited
because these seniors
you know they had never ever created an
artwork for public display before
and that got them really excited at the
same time very nervous
you know whether they can create
something that is of um you know
presentation quality
you know that is good enough for public
display
um but well the artists guided them
along and the seniors got very excited
to the extent they even went down to see
their work being you know
installed onto the onto the public space
into the public space
right and all these are done by seniors
who are 70 plus years old
and finally when the public installation
was launched the community were very
surprised
because they actually did not know that
this group of seniors even existed in
their neighborhood even though they
stayed there for so many years
and this is a very good chance for
seniors to feel proud of themselves and
also for the neighborhood to learn about
this senior's existence
and this public art installation no
longer just become like a
feel good look good product but it
actually says tells a story for the
community
and it also helps to give self esteem to
the seniors
so after a nine months display of this
exhibit the seniors actually wanted
all these things back because they feel
so emotionally attached
to the art piece through the product to
the public art installation
so i think all these things again proven
that if we were to just use a more
you know participatory approach to
things it could really go a long way
right to even building ownership and
also to celebrate the community building
that emotional attachment to it
now people often also ask me you know
what i've shared so far are products uh
public spaces
are interior spaces but what about
actual
you know research product or even
content can participatory design
also create that emotional attachment to
it
so for the last example i'm going to
share is this particular collaboration
we did with the ministry of health of
singapore
um what we want to do is we wanted to
create content
that we call the national diabetes
reference material with the public
now in the past what this national
diabetes reference material is used for
is to inform the public about anything
about diabetes
so whenever i want to find out something
about diabetes as a diabetic patient
or as a caregiver i can just refer to
this materials and that's it right
i can know all the information from this
now i think ministry of health do not
just want to create a material that
you know is from the doctors or from the
experts we really want to understand the
need of the public
and then create the content of this
diabetes reference material so how did
we do it right
we went down to the neighborhood we
created i think we had six pop-up
sessions that we pop up in different
parts of singapore
to really go to where the diabetes
diabetic patients and their caregivers
are
right to really hear from them you know
what are your struggles
what exactly are your you know are your
concerns when it comes to diabetes
and we even got our ministry of health
offices who are usually just sitting in
their office to actually come down to
listen
and it was really very amazing because
these people who are usually in front of
the computer thought that their contents
are easy to understand
but when they do the engagement that's
when they realize you know actually what
i thought is easy for people to
understand
it's not that understandable after all
and that was when they decided like to
tweak the content to make it a little
bit more accessible for everyday people
right and we even talked to many people
who are not your usual
frequent guests or focus group
discussions to get their views as well
and after that we also created this
citizen engagement workshop whereby we
invite people from all walks of life
to discuss even further in depth in
terms of content
and also in terms of the design of the
whole material with us
and eventually what we have was a very
amazing thing because
you know people who follow through the
process got very invested in it
you know they really want to find out
what happened to the materials and right
now the materials are online
right it's available in the ministry of
health website and from what we
understand the take up rate and the
download rate is really high because
it is content that is created by the
citizens and they feel very proud of it
and they feel a sense of you know
achievement in the sense of attachment
to the content they created
so by doing this kind of co-creation
process it again have shown that there
has a lot of potential
for even a product or content to make
people feel emotionally attached to them
right so all right now i will share
three examples
that really are very short examples that
showcase how participatory design
could have an impact in many many
different areas but ultimately
i think what we want to say is that you
know when it comes to emotive design or
participation design
every individual has something positive
to contribute to the co-creation and
design process
and i think i hope that after this
sharing we can see everybody as
collaborators
and not just as consumers and by having
that humility and
mindset you know i think we would
definitely go a long way to create
emotive spaces
that really mean something to people
and of course um that ends by sharing
and there's a qr code right here
if you guys are interested to download
like a little cheat sheet
of what it means to design with
communities
feel free to scan the qr code right uh
it's a pdf file
that shows some of the steps and tips
that we use um
to co-create with our communities right
so feel free to kind of download it
and with this i'll add my sharing and of
course um
mix up there's also a very interesting
speaker who is also very inspiring for
myself
and i'll pass the time over to trisha
who will share more about her
perspective and her journey
on emotive design right so trisha i'll
pass the time over to
you thank you thank you larry hi
everyone afternoon
um now let me set uh a lot of great
points out there
that i can't agree more with um
very inspiring really um and i can't
agree more about what collaboration
really means that every one of us has
something to give
so today um anyway i'm trisha i'm from
recreate studio
so um today i will share a bit more
about the kind of work that we create
does
what we believe in and i'll show two
case studies on the work that
we've been working on for the last four
years now
since 2017
i think um we create idea they started
off with uh
intent to really look at architectural
and design consultancy for the social
good
that again we emphasize on the fact that
participatory design what it actually
means
can be contextualized a little bit
different from what larry is talking
about because we're working with
a lot of different communities around
the region we focus our on southeast
asia
who has very different cultural context
very different language from us very
different understanding of their space
and their world from us so the kind of
engagement we do
um varies and has to be suited
to the needs it may not involve very
often workshops because the language
barrier is not there they might not even
understand that
needs we engage a little bit more on a
one-to-one basis and families and family
bases
with these rural communities i'll
explain a bit more about work through
the case study in a while
and more important is when we engage
them they understand what's going on in
the whole design process
they tell you in a different way what
they need they may not already tell you
what they need because
the time they don't know what they need
which is in any of the design process
actually
and through the process they gain
ownership of what
eventually gets delivered to them their
ownership is something that
empowers them in the process and by
empowering them
you are actually giving them the chance
to
to to do what they need to do for
themselves in the long run
because at the end of the day what we
want to do instead of uh those things we
want to do is instead of helping them
that we became a dependency they we
became a
platform of dependency for them i think
that's the last thing we want to do so
it's right we are very intentional to
make sure that they get involved and we
have a timeline for all our projects
we see that ourselves as a bridge
i mean there's some things that we share
a fair bit well with some of our very
close friends
a very slow bridging process to bridge
the
gaps of needs and bridge that gaps of
between resources
available resources the opportunities
with the beneficiaries
very often we are so
uh not just we i think a lot of us are
also
wanting to help so much that uh we jump
into the
wanting to help but what is actually
help we make sure that we're actually
helping sometimes
the intention of help may not be enough
yeah sometimes we wanted to help end up
making the situation even worse in the
long run so
we how can we actually build bridges uh
without actually destroying
uh in the process it's very important i
think this is something that we're very
conscious in mind as we
build the kind of products we're looking
at
um so be about our mission um
we look at a long-term
social impact in all our works so i
emphasize on the word long term because
the kind of communities you work with
it's not something that a lot of us come
in and do the buildings and then we
disappear
and that's it you know especially in
architect we just built we think that
it's just a building but we emphasize on
the fact of the skill sets of an
architect to deliver long-term social
impact
in my long-term experience in our case
study and i mentioned earlier
empowering the community in the
processes is really our mission every
day in whatever projects that we do
and our approach is really to discuss
the community to help them think
big on what they really want to do
and still start the smallest of what
they can get to in the first place
wherever they are at the resources and
more important is we guide them along to
see
impacts in whatever decision we make of
they may not be fully aware we just have
to prompt them
i think larry sometimes jasmine
mentioned sometimes they may not know
what they want they will just
say uh i only want to build a school but
then they after the process
they realize you will realize that they
don't just need a school they need
education
opportunities for education is quite
different yeah
and we believe in innovation in the
process innovation doesn't have to be a
big it innovation that we talk about in
singapore very much
innovation is just can also be about how
you can do things a little bit
differently
in their daily lives these are
innovation in a more adaptive way
suited for the rural communities that we
work with very much
and we believe very much in the learning
loop uh just i mentioned that
um proposing one do is really
come and build a building like what
architects or architects are usually
very good at
and then we leave we emphasize our
project that is a
looping process so that we can be better
in each process that we do
each direction that we do we build we
measure or monitor the kind of work or
impact that we have
is it really impactful reaching the
effect that we want it to be
and then we learn from it maybe we will
rebuild certain portions of it we're
developing the different portions of it
or maybe we will
develop it to the next project that we
do um there must be a constant
about learning that's what's important
and i think before we want to jump in
with a good heart we must understand the
real
problem problem behind it uh i mentioned
earlier sometimes what may be
at you as a problem like uh i'll share
with you in a case study in a while
uh it may not be the source of the issue
or may not be the real problem statement
that we're looking at
so i'll show you this process that we
started off thinking got us
thinking in one of our projects for the
tiwa primary school which
will be the case study number one if you
have some we are familiar with this
fishbone structure uh
if not uh is something where we a
structure that we look at to look at
breaking down issues uh to review more
or to uncover more in-depth
understanding
so one of the questions we ask is i
think not just me i think um
a lot of us have been contributing maybe
financially or maybe be involved in
children's home or have a hand insurance
home
around southeast asia or even around
asia but do you realize that
despite all your efforts some of you may
be a bit more there are still a lot of
children swimming in the southeast asia
and then sometimes even more in some
regions for example borders of thailand
which is some of the areas that we focus
a fair bit beyond
there's still a high number of children
in the orphanage in southeast asia
region
despite all the efforts and many years
of having involved myself in working
with children's home
but why is that so we started to ask
ourselves and then these symptoms lead
to overcrowded
overcrowded orphanage uh we have
overcrowd overcrowded orphanages
resources get thin out you may not even
have enough food so you got the
prioritized priorities
uh the basic stability versus uh a more
educated secondary
education and then and this direct
course
is such that you will see that many
children are sent to the orphanage for
better education better food
no no parents would want to send their
children away
but often they have to do this make this
decision uh to send the children away
far away from them in order for them to
have a chance in life
so i want the underlying statements a
symptoms that we we i mentioned earlier
that the insufficient support sensory
cells for every children
and i think one of the underlying causes
that we
realize it that there's insufficient
funds and at home to support family and
the lack of opportunities in villages
this realization may ask very much in
our next statement
and the kind of work that we set up to
do especially for the third primary
school
so how might we create opportunities for
the local communities really
this opportunity come in different form
depending on the needs of the
communities
but we need to create opportunity right
at the village of the softs of the
issues themselves
uh i feel that i mean at the end of the
day i think the realization is that
the issue is not the children so the
issue is at the at their home itself if
they are given a chance not to leave
their home and if there is enough job
over there they have enough opportunity
over there
they will not choose to leave their home
nobody would in a rational mind
so the technique we employ to engage the
community very much you may have
heard about empathy so this screenshot
that you see on screen right now
is extract from the change magazine if
you all didn't know about this magazine
it's an online magazine that shares
about
the change movement around the world and
i thought this
statement that they made in their
magazine cover page was very appropriate
for discussion
empathy the solutions for forgotten
formula
um we're so used to we're so used to in
our society especially in singapore's
spin context that to look from a very
top down point even to look at what's
the most efficient way of doing things
what's the most uh
effective way what's the
resource-consuming way on the fastest
way even to do things sometimes fastest
may not be for the best yeah
sometimes but empathy i think empathy is
very important
and what's the difference between
empathy and sympathy right
in order to be really sensible in the
kind of solution that we come up with
it's very important it's very important
to differentiate what's empathy versus
sympathy we don't want to
have sympathy actually none of the
communities that we require sympathy at
all
none of them but they do require empathy
to understand the situation they are in
in order to relieve them from the
difficulties that they face
very much and provide empathy
i think i don't know they it's easy to
categorize things
it's easy to categorize boxes
of what we think each each of the
communities need
but the power averages is a terrible way
i think to design solutions for the
people
everyone is individual individually
different let me mention that everyone
is different
everyone has their own solutions um we
may not know all
and we don't want to come in with the
fact that we know all
and then try to impose what we think we
know all actually most of time they will
know more than you
who they know their own life they know
their environment more than you do for
sure
they grow up in it so i'll start to
share two case studies uh hopefully to a
process that helps us understand the
kind of what we do
uh the kind of engagement we do so these
two projects are the myanmar
thai borders uh given the myanmar
situation political situation
out there right now these two villagers
are also on the tension but to be honest
for all the years i've been working then
they have been on tension every every
week
every day it's just that sometimes
whether the media blows it up or not so
this two
village tewado village is a karen
village
the learning village is the it's a
caring village in the
current state so they are karen is a
very diverse group of people
they are considered self-care uh by
academic categories
um and um the
when these communities came to us uh me
and my partner or my
friend in thailand they told us they
needed a school that was in 2017.
they tell us can we help them build a
school that was the instruction
given but at the end of the day uh
i mean i think the process was
interesting is that they don't know
what's an architect there's no such
thing called architect in their language
they don't they can't speak english they
can't
a lot of them can't even speak burmese
only the young the youth can speak some
burmese
most of them can't speak thai no english
so it's really a lot of sign language
when i'm in these communities and this
is not
uncommon for all the communities that
would worry so a lot of sign language a
lot of smiles
a lot trying to understand observations
of
uh through watching them in their daily
needs and a daily affairs
and a little bit of translation here and
there to our friends
really um they thought they needed a
school
we took a long time i literally had
somebody that came up
one of the younger girls i think sorry i
was 16 17.
she was our translator for that day one
of the one of the earlier discussion on
they literally asked me can we come here
and start the work tomorrow
like literally tomorrow can we start
with tomorrow and i was like uh not
really
tomorrow we need to understand the real
the real conversations i
take on don't we we'll get there we'll
get there we'll definitely get the
school going but it may just take about
three or four years
to get this whole thing out you ended up
taking three years by the way
so she didn't understand why it takes so
many years for them they want to build a
hut
the bamboo heart next door in their
house they look to
do it the next day and get it going
so uh to share about the design process
or education process so talk to them
before we start any design was a very
uh interesting for them can you imagine
this is their next big thing in the
whole village and then why am i holding
back all this whole design process so it
was a bit frustrating there was a bit of
communication issues in the beginning
they were really expecting us to come in
as soon as possible to build and then
especially because
they are in the jungle area so they have
half a year monsoon and half a year of
dry season
you can never cross you can never do any
contracting in the monsoon because all
the rivers are at the highest
no trucks can cross you have to it's a
four-wheel drive that if you want to
drive you cannot get into that area
so um so we only have exactly half a
year to build
each time so it took us a much longer
time and more important is the design
process took about one and a half years
actually
so when my design process really to go
to every door
door to door talking to different
communities how i talk
i talk to sign language i talk to a
translator i talk through
having copied them and then like
patronizing their
freshly freshly fried wild vegetable
jungle vegetables
most of them are urban foragers so to
them they think that
allowing their children to have
education is the only way that the
children do not have to go through the
hardship that they face
so to them this school is so important
so important but
through the processes not so much on the
daily project
but through these design processes it
was this conclusion that we came to that
they don't just need a school
they need educational opportunities um
education not in a way what we know
academics and then doing abc out there
really don't mean too much for them
because once the because of
political situation this group of caring
people they cannot go beyond grade 10 in
short
they are not in a different they are in
a different national system because of
the differences in the ethnic groups so
what they
realize in phase two is actually a skill
set development program
that we developed for them they never
knew they needed that to be honest they
don't even know what skills that they
want to program they just helped we just
asked them what would you like to learn
other than school
so just go to different groups of people
what would you like to do what do you
think we would like to learn if we give
you the chance
that means we will provide all the funds
to provide opportunity we bring the
facilitators we acted beyond
an architect the role of an architect we
facilitated
opportunity for them to learn and all
these communities out there they have
their own innovation their own talent
the teachers will tell them say they
wish they can teach better and they wish
they can have a printer to print notes
but printer is a bit challenging because
they're all free we literally had to
have a lot of solar panels out there on
the top of the roof
just to install one uh one printer but
even with printer we
thought it's not sustainable in the long
run because once you run out ink that's
it
maintenance is a big issue over there so
maintenance for every product we do
we need to know what happens when we
leave what are they able to maintain on
their own what they are not so there's a
whole set of conversation
going on about the about the
architectural disease
decision which is separate but i want to
share about the process about engagement
so this picture on the left is really
a friend of ours eric i think he's in a
conversation today also
um to partner with eric
a singaporean who runs a kind of school
in yangon
to partner with them to bring
opportunity for the local teachers the
local youth men
and to have skill sets so the local
youth might tell me say that they want
to do
they want to build a fixed motor because
not much people out there know how to
speak more
fixed motors uh in their region so they
don't learn
mechanical skill set and carpentry skill
sets that they just want to teach a
little bit better
so we brought through skill set
development program supposed to start
last year but because of the covet you
got halt
uh to bring back this skill set to
homework this uh skill set development
program
and the picture on the right we're going
to share a little bit more behind the
process is that
uh you see these two boys there on day
you look at the toys that you
you are familiar with maybe some of your
nephews and nieces or your children have
when you just stick that push the toys
around and these
two i find it the most innovative toy
that they
was made out of just rival rubbish they
found around them really it's just
bamboo
bamboo body uh with wheels that not
matching at all
and just a a rattan stick that they
found in the jungle
to push it along and i find this one of
the most innovative
toy i ever seen so the second project
we'll share about is uh
a clinic construction this clinic is
still under construction at this stage
all got swooped up because of kovit
because nobody could cross reaching
villages
this community is for the hmong hmong is
a tribe also in the hmong state
the joker proud village
among very different because at
different tracks they have very
different working structure with the
south karen even though they're just
adjacent to each other
so um this clinic uh design process is
also very interesting because
the hmong committees has their own ngo
which is called the hmong national
health committee it's something like our
local
moh sort of but they are nonprofit
so um they are a little bit more
structured
in terms of organizing among themselves
so they they show us the different
uh the different clinics around the
region they don't exactly have hospitals
in this jungle area
they don't really have doctors at all
most of them are medics
of between 16 to 20 over years old
very young clinics are medics also so
they get rotated between the villages
but more importantly through this
engagement exercise the committee i
asked the community say why don't you
want to build your clinic on your own
they say they have no resources and
don't know how to
because all the existing clinic is
really just a room at their own day
and don't even have no chance to store
bad scenes so
they ask us to share with them how to
build so basically we have conversations
with the
uh the local communities a fair bit
because they're more a little bit more
structured we don't have to go
door to door they came to us it helps us
a bit to avoid the sun
so there's a lot of conversation going
on and there are other communities is so
willing to give their hand
to help put this whole uh construction
together so
they have a stake on um on the materials
very often i'm learning from them more
than they more than i'm
guiding them they tell us exactly what
materials can be sourced around here
within the community we try not to buy
from a file we try to bring the money
back to them
and buy the local bricks by their local
rattan by their local
cement but the steel we have to buy from
afar and even transportation of the
sizes of the structure members is tricky
because it takes nine hours from the
nearest town
to this village and it's through jungle
roads so logistics is crazy so
um they guide us along on how to bring
this whole construction together
so early on i just said about the
learning village which is a six years
initiative we bring into phase one phase
two through the process to understand
the needs
and then also about the clinic among
construction clinics for the joker pro
community that's still under
construction um
some other projects that we have done
and are ongoing right now uh
are still developing but kobe has
changed quite a fair bit of discussion
this is the very last slide i will share
and i'll round off the conversation that
at the end of the day i think we all
have to
give i think very important is um we are
in the
society where to understand everyone is
the same i feel that
we're just human at their own day we
have a lot to give in whatever capacity
we are especially speaking from
singapore there's a lot we can give
but can we come together and give more
appropriately and more collectively as a
whole
to bring long-term impact it's too easy
i cannot say they are wrong or anyone is
wrong but it's too easy to just give
without thinking too much we need to
give and think more
deeply about how are we giving how are
we benefiting them in the long run
it's so easy to just donate clothes
donate i don't know donate books donate
clothes
but do you realize that all these quotes
and books when it goes to certain areas
becomes waste
management problem for many of them um
how can we give more uh effectively and
more sustainably
in the long run how can we come together
with different skill sets to form a
collective
uh to be more effective to come in more
effective solutions
i leave we all live to this discussion
with a lot more questions and
i think this is all that i have to do
and this video you're looking at is
basically at tiwado primary school uh
the children are just leaving
for the end of the day thank you very
much yes thank you so much trisha for
sharing that i think it was really
interesting and i hope everyone also had
a better idea of how
you know participation design and
emotions actually have a really
big connection all right i think uh
yeah i think victor has a question
actually uh now i think we are moving on
to the question segment
okay i think we're trying to answer as
many questions as you guys have
um i think victor has a question maybe
trisha or just uh
we just open up to you first right when
people
open up during the process of
participatory design you know they get
emotionally attached right so
how do we protect their emotions and how
do we respect their feelings in the
final design
any any any situations treasure for you
you know like
that you know the resident wanted
something but ended up the final design
didn't really reflect that
how do you deal with it actually uh
most of the time when we go with uh
rural communities they usually have the
uh maybe a bit different from that you
share your process later did you have
the block base
they just added they just need a school
or anyone they just need a plate
um the expectation is very different
between what we
what matters to us and what matters to
them at the end of the day um
i think maybe i'll share a little bit
different or what went wrong
miss com
me as a designer or me as a naturalist i
was very attached to
a big tree a huge rainforest tree
outside the uh the school uh the tiwado
school
but to the committee i realized that it
was just another tree
it was just another tree so emotionally
i write a texture because i think there
was so much activities going on i think
it's a fantastic tree
and but when we started the construction
there was some mixed calm where
the next thing i knew the tree they
really cut down the entire tree because
they felt that the branches are in the
way of the
upcoming school so
through this example i realized that
emotional attachment very different
differs a lot between cultures and
between contexts
uh for them they are more attached to
to the idea of having a school itself
and how how can that realization happen
for the next generation
so i think the communication of
emotional attachment changes
in context in culture in background
very much uh in the kind of engagement
that we do
so to find that common language is a
very
challenging process for us um but it's
something that we take time and take
care to do
maybe let me share a bit more maybe less
tricky than mine
i i think definitely you know i think
when uh you know when some
when the community provides strongly on
something and then they really want it
done they really want it done now
um i mean for example like the senior
activity center example that i shared
um i think like i mentioned right you
know they really really like bingo if
you take away their bingo space you know
they really really will be crazy with
you and so then we talk together with
the center staff
um definitely there are some constraints
right we cannot i mean we have to take
out some kind of space
but we're gonna kind of really explain
to the seniors you know why we are
making certain decisions
i think at the end of the day seniors
are not unreasonable or even the
residents per se are not unreasonable
i think all they want are is
accountability meaning you know they
want to know why you make certain
decisions
and i think if that process is done well
and the accountability part is done well
uh actually i think there's not much
issue in the long run you know i think
actually it is okay
yeah but anyway there's still actually a
lot more questions i'm gonna try to
answer as much
as we can there's quite a lot of
questions over here um
i think there's one very interesting
question from ann uh who actually asked
about the rules of negative emotions in
the work that we do
yeah any thoughts on that if not maybe i
can start first ratio because
i have something to share about this
negative go ahead you go ahead i think
i think for any engagement if you think
that every engagement i just positive
emotion it's not possible i can tell you
every attachment there will be some
negative
emotions into it but i think for us is
to understand
where this negativity come from right so
it's again you know about asking like
the first activity i run through with
you guys right is
really asking the why and and how how do
we address it yes you're not happy with
it
but what can we do together to make it
better for you right
so even like you know in some words that
we do like you know neighborhood
upgrading
or public space design you know
sometimes people say yeah i just want a
whole basketball called gone you know
it's so
noisy but um but sometimes when you
actually understand why
you know then you realize that okay you
know you real i mean then you kind of
get other people to share their ideas
then this person can also see okay i
understand why i cannot remove the
basketball court
right and i think all these
communications between the communities
actually helped to kind of turn these
negative emotions into something that's
more constructive
and i think participation design do
facilitate that process to cover some of
this negative energy
to something more constructive but of
course it doesn't happen all the time
i must say sometimes people are just so
negative they don't want to kind of do
anything about it but
as much as possible i think we provide
that platform for people to kind of do
that
right but i'm not sure for your overseas
experience like you know
how how is that like for you uh
yeah actually i have to somewhere maybe
a little bit
different from larry again because of
the situation that we face
um again i'm especially usually when i
work with
rural communities when i say rural
communities mainly just villagers and
communities they're usually quite easy
going
but they're very very strong about their
heritage
or differences in heritage so one of the
situations i remember i was a bit
shocked it didn't
occur to me until it happened so we
completed
doing the primary school first so we the
idea was to have a
group of craftsmen to follow us through
each project
so that i mean technically we don't have
to keep emphasizing what
is expected of and what is that we know
we're good we just want to
give them a job in the long run since
we're familiar working in them
i also realized that because the school
is a
is a caring village the next project
clinic was a hmong village
so the whole group across men don't want
to go to the hmong village to work
because
because it's wrong so and then there's
only one uncle who
is uh saving grace um uncle jolene and
unfortunately uncle julius
just passed on just a month back because
of illness
only uncle julian followed us through
and he was okay
to deal with the negative thoughts or
not so positive talks
from the different villages uh the
committees
different from them so i think that
grief and anger can be very
can be very these are decades of hatreds
are talking about here
uh it's not something that can stop
overnight and we can and we
were trying to save the world something
i i i don't see myself doing that
sometimes you just have to let things go
through and let them sort it out
themselves it's like you know children
sometimes just have to better solve
their own problem you can't stop waiting
for them you can only guide them
yeah i don't think if they're not
willing to patch they're not willing to
patch
so this one thing that really came to us
and uh participatory was same thing um
when you when you when you talk to the
karen you get the camera talk to them
their own character you don't have any
other groups of people talking to them
they will not
they will not tell you because i'm a
foreigner so it's a different case
altogether you cannot have heavy
different heritage talking to them this
is in yemen context so we started
working also in cambodia uh before the
kobe started
cambodia because it's siem reap um
they are more open to tourism so they
have seen foreigners before they have
seen differences before
they are open to differences so it's
very much
how open the committee are to engage you
and how they are
open to conversations with you is very
much about how much exposure they have
with the outside world with the rest of
the world
so for for for myanmar it has its own
political situations
for campbell there depends on which part
of cambodia you're at
xiame is a little bit more open because
of tourism so there was less issue
working with them
with the communities so maybe negative
emotions in that context for the kind of
what we've been doing
yeah trisha there's another question
here from homecare to you
would you actually say that
participation design is a process that
can transcend language and culture
especially from the experience working
across the region
uh i say a smile brings
a smile helps a lot um
i would say transcend yes i would like
to think so um i think
the best learning curve for us is really
working with the myanmar communities
myanmas communities of different
language especially with tiwardo because
almost none of them spoke english but we
still managed to get conversation
interviews and i was interviews are
really just copy sessions and chatting
with them through
um and most of the time it's also a
chance for their young children to
practice english with me too so it
becomes a conversation
topic to to try and practice english
but very minimal english what we can
what we can get our bit very often are
it's a lot about
adaptability um um to get the
information that you need
um it's a bit different when you have
the same language you can get into the
conversation straight away very often
you need to be sitting there for a while
sometimes days sometimes weeks before
they open up to you yeah remember at the
end of day
it's not that you come to save the world
trying to say that they are their
village
they must remember that we are we are i
was trying to remember that i'm a
foreigner i'm nobody over there
i'm just facilitating we're just
facilitating opportunities for them
so we cannot come with assumptions so i
think it will
transcend and i hope to get better
in observational skills so the kind of
engagement exercises changes
with the kind of capacity of engagement
that we can have
yeah okay i think we have final two two
questions i think one question is for me
um i think asking what happens after
projects that i have we have done does
it end up as a showcase or is it
designed for a longer tail
long-tail outcome now andre uh regarding
this question i think
of course uh sometimes some projects we
we kind of do
you know climb whatever they use as a
showcase but ultimately what i feel
is that moving beyond showcase is also
about you know
how this whole participant process
actually teaches them also
so it's not just about us you know going
in and doing something but it's also
educating the client in a process that
hey you know you can actually use this
kind of process to co-create with your
seniors
so even after when we leave it i would
say yes the design of that space
itself is a showcase but then the
programs that they continue to co-create
with the seniors to sustain the space
then become something that has more
long-term outcomes so i think for me yes
i won't deny that yes the project
definitely will become a showcase
somewhat
but how they continue the process to
make use of the space
i think is where you know the domestic
smart happener if you have done a good
process
i think that is also something that you
can see you know after you leave the
space the center is still very vibrant
people are still coming down because
like i say co-creation is not just down
on the space but it's also extended to
creating programs for the seniors so i
think that is where
i really feel very happy is that so far
a lot of our projects have the
continuity
and it's really nice to see la yeah in
the long run
and of course that being said i think
this is a link to the last question that
i have over here to round up
before today's session uh i think of
course also i mean also i think i
applied to trishala
you know sometimes when the stakeholder
and community are working with one one
thing
and then you know the group want another
thing you know
how do we negotiate that
yeah so i think actually yeah actually i
think we have the experience right you
want to share
what are your thoughts about it i think
that's bound to be
i see as a i mean it can be very
frustrating about in the beginning but i
think after a while you get used to it
you get used to it really i think it's
good that everyone everyone has
different expectations
i mean if if you're interested in the
project or in the commitment that you
have
you will have expectations i think it's
natural human human
humanity um the thing is that's why i
see it as a we see ourselves as a bridge
i'd like to see this way
uh to bridge that gaps gaps of
differences get of uh
interest and to see how it can
creatively come out solutions to marry
uh different uh different expectations
together very often it's about managing
expectation i mean it's just like any
other designer if any of your ideas
i think many of you should be a lot of
designers here it's not about managing
expectations
for your clients from your stakeholders
not just in participatory design
and it depends on how you converse
people and how you creatively
come up with solutions i think that's
where creativity creativity is about
it's not just making things pretty
it's about solving problems solving
solutions that can
kind of bring differences and
expectations together
very often we should be able to find
that solution so far
yeah think it's uh yeah it's frustrating
definitely according to what she should
say but i think
when you actually sit down together and
talk to me i think that's when things
will be better
and and i think in any participation
design process right i think uh
this thing is about to happen but it's
really about also our role as designers
or our role as architects you know um
you know
how you want to educate your client the
process also because sometimes client
will be making a decision because they
don't know the process
right but if you sit down explain to
them usually they will understand that
oh i understand
why you need so much time because okay
you want to set the direction right you
know
so i think it's also about education you
know a true listener process about
empathy
about and understanding where your
client or your partners are coming from
or soon because
i i mean they have their concerns as
well right it's not like their concerns
are
not valid so participation design is
also about you know addressing
everybody's concern and that includes
your funders and stakeholders as well so
i think once we have that settled
actually most of the time it is okay
yes so i think yeah i think the key to
making a good project work really is
just to have the heart and the patience
in order to deal with all these things
like it's never easy but uh
but yeah but i think it's the there's an
empathy that brings you
you know to go on in the long run yeah
so
uh yeah i think with this uh i i think i
really want to thank everybody for your
time today i think it was a great
session
i'm mindful of time so i think with this
i'll just pass the time back over to
design singapore
uh who will round up to this session and
it was a pleasure meeting all of you and
yeah anything just feel free to drop us
an email we'll be happy to answer and
continue the conversation
yes thank you for all your time also to
spend your next your last one hour with
us
and i think you can get us also on our
social media
platforms uh which i listed here but you
can easily find us
um and i think there's a lot of
questions i think larry there's a lot of
questions that is out there we haven't
answered yet
we'll try to answer to it like if you
can leave your contacts somehow
sure yeah we'll get it from design
singapore so with that i'll pass the
time over the dsg
yes thank you thank you all